Kim Kardashian was almost on the hills  no seriously oh yes MTV and Lauren  Conrad teamed up once again for the much  awaited the hills that was then this is  now special on Tuesday and the show left  us with some shocking revelations like  Tim K made a cameo alongside Heidi  Montag shortly after her sex tape with  Ray J turned her into the hottest new  celeb in Hollywood are you going to the  VMAs yeah for Vegas in the morning  Lauren also confessed what went down  when she and ex-boyfriend Jason Wahler  broke up I said you have three innocent  your stuff out I'm having the locks  changed on Monday and that was how we  broke up and everything between she and  the Keeping Up stars stepbrother Brody  Jenner was fate  the most shocking revelation the reality  star turned fashion designer says her  husband of two years William Tell has  never seen the hills I think the most  interesting thing about him is that he  just has never seen the show